this week
the world's going to have to invest in
about 14 trillion dollars worth
of grid in order to accommodate all the
capacity that's going to be put on
connecting the dots to turn on the
lights if countries around the world
want to meet their renewable targets
they're going to need a reliable way to
deliver clean energy
we look at some of the solutions the
united states
simply doesn't have the same kind of
transmission infrastructure
to move power around and and that's
really going to be a problem going
forward
the united states is in the midst of an
energy transition
but how do we move an entire country's
power grid from fossil fuels to a
cleaner alternative
what we're contributing here is the
potential to grow
so essentially no one is left behind in
the race to development
in the race to making our energy more
green and what about people off the grid
we look at one company helping rural
communities power themselves
i'm kaylee lymes and this is bloomberg
[Music]
nearly half of the world's electricity
will come from renewable energy by 2050
as costs of wind solar and battery
storage continue to plummet
but creating clean energy is only half
the battle
the other half comes from how we
transfer it from where it's produced
to where it's needed
electrical grids are getting old in the
u.s parts are over a century old
despite its age it's surprisingly
reliable with a few notable exceptions
this morning the power crisis in texas
entering its fourth
painful day and these exceptions are
likely to increase
with more demand and pressure from
climate change
our current model of electricity
generation and transmission works a
little like a waterfall
the generator sits at the top be it
fossil fuel power
nuclear hydro or from renewables the
electricity flows down
into substations that use transformers
to convert the energy into practical
voltages
which sends it via wire to homes and
businesses
sensors monitor how much electricity
goes where and meters on the back end
record how much gets used
this incredibly simplified portrait of
electrical grids
shows how all energy flows in one
direction it's a top-heavy centralized
power structure but the proliferation of
renewables
are allowing end users to generate their
own electricity
and in some cases surpluses that can be
sent back to the grid
these areas are called microgrids
islands of self-contained power
or ideally decentralized generators
connected into a larger grid system
how to regulate all this power flowing
up and down over a massive transmission
network is a huge policy issue
right now in the u.s federally regulated
central generators sell power in an
auction market to distributors which are
generally regulated by states
with more small generators coming online
it's unclear if this patchwork approach
is going to work
and doubtful that it will be the most
efficient system another aspect of
renewables to reckon with
is that optimization for these power
sources often situates them in locations
far from the final customer this differs
from older fossil fuel power stations
that were built
closer to municipalities offshore wind
farms are the perfect example
how do we move the power generated back
on shore at reasonable cost
moving electricity is a little like
trying to run with a bucket full of
water
some electricity is lost during
transmission in the form of heat
which compounds over long distances one
solution that's being proposed is
essentially a bigger bucket
giant ultra high voltage direct current
cables that would connect power grids
internationally
an added advantage would be that
renewables if given transmission
capacity
could power the dark side of the earth
while the flip side is in sunshine
further reducing our reliance on fossil
fuels to provide constant energy
the cost of building this massive
infrastructure project will be huge and
regulating it will take perhaps more
international cooperation
than ever seen before
well ever since president xi jinping
pitched the idea of a global energy
internet to the united nations six years
ago china has been trying to persuade
the world to build high voltage highways
that would form its backbone
that plan to wrap the planet in a web of
intercontinental made in beijing power
lines has gone
pretty much nowhere but the fortunes of
so-called super grids appear to be
turning
just maybe not on the scale she first
envisioned
joining me now is mark champion
bloomberg senior reporter for
international affairs who has been
covering this story for us
so china's all over this why and should
that concern
anyone well yeah it's a good question i
mean what the main reason why china's
done it is that they had to develop this
their grid at such a space just because
of the
scale of growth in china over the last
couple of decades
and they were trying to you know knit
together some
pretty shaky grids in order to
really get power to all those factories
that were manufacturing everything for
the world
and more recently what they've started
to do is to say hey
if we have a large renewable
energy solar or wind
plant that or farm that's going
producing electricity out in tibet so
what they've done is to
develop these really long lines longer
than anyone else has
developed before at higher voltages that
anyone else has developed before
and they've connected them up um as to
whether anyone should be worried i mean
it's a
it's a very good question what china is
saying is we need to
build these grids all over the world so
first of all that's a pretty good
commercial proposition for china
they'll do very well in terms of trade
and then
secondly it raises questions you know
who's going to control this global grid
who's going to set the standards uh you
know and does that matter and for some
people
it it does they they worry uh that it'll
be a little bit like
when the us built the uh global
financial
system after world war ii um and that
you know it's not like the us
owns uh the financial system the global
financial system everybody takes part in
it
and yet it gave the u.s enormous
influence and we've discovered that more
and more quite recently
uh so there's some concern about that
these ideas aren't new they have been
around for a long time but there were
barriers in the past to getting them
built
at scale why would this time be
different
uh yeah absolutely it's uh these things
are not popular these are huge cables
often they're overground and they have
to go through a lot of people's
backyards
uh so it's you know not popular for that
reason
very difficult more difficult in a
democracy where people get to decide
whether they want them going overhead
and you know on top of that you know
countries aren't generally
crazy about volunteering
to depend on another country for
electricity
with oil if you don't have oil you kind
of have to you have to buy your oil from
saudi arabia or the us or elsewhere
with natural gas you may have to buy it
from russia because you don't have your
own
but with electricity you know you can
build your own plant you know
everybody's got
some sun everybody's got some wind some
have more than others but you can do it
yourself so
in general it hasn't been absolutely
necessary it was something that
for example the european union did uh
after the war to
build a sort of more competitive a
bigger grid and it's good for
uh making sure that as with texas this
winter if you have some
major problem in your grid you can turn
on the tap from another one and borrow
some electricity buy some electricity
and it means that you don't have to shut
off the lights what's changed now
is that with renewables uh you know
if you have a big coal plant you can
just sit it next to the city you want to
serve
if you have renewables you know offshore
uh like the uk has been building some
huge offshore wind
uh plant uh farms uh in the north sea
if you if you want to develop that you
can't do it
next to london you have to put your
offshore wind
where the wind is which in this case is
offshore if you look at
just how much uh the
climate targets imply that countries are
going to have to
increase the amount of electricity that
they produce and to generate
well they're going to have to get that
from somewhere a lot of it will be micro
produced on people's
roofs in small utility plants
close to cities but that probably isn't
going to be enough
so if i'm looking for renewable energy
solutions
are cables my answer uh they're one
answer and
not everybody believes that they are the
you know the best answer
for some they're a kind of old-school
you know old think
uh way of producing energy because it's
kind of centralized you know the
the chinese love this because it's
centralized you can control it centrally
you're building huge utility scale power
centers
um which are a little it's like a
renewable nuclear plant or a renewable
coal plant
um but for others uh that you know
there's there's greater
interest security efficiency in
producing really micro generation uh
and connecting those in smart grids um
so there's
there's different ideas about how this
is going to pan out
but the sort of consensus is you're
going to need it all
that the amount of power that we're
going to need to generate in addition
to what you know the i think bloomberg
new energy finances estimated that uh
the world's going to have to produce
invest in about 14 trillion dollars
worth
of grid uh in order to
accommodate all the capacity that's
going to be put on
and some of that is likely uh it's
pretty certain uh we can see it
happening now
that it's going to be these big cables
the question is you know how much
all right mark champion bloomberg senior
reporter for international affairs thank
you so much
and you can read mark's businessweek
piece in full on your terminal or
on bloomberg.com coming up
the road to clean energy we all know we
need to get there
but how we'll speak to author russell
gold on how to take the next steps
on the path to green plus we've looked
at super grids but what about
mini grids we'll explore the sustainable
energy solutions powering
rural communities this is bloomberg
this is bloomberg green i'm jennifer
zabasaja in new york with your green
brief
the g7 is dropping its target for
electric vehicles instead it's now only
pledging to speed up efforts to phase
out the combustion engine
but it didn't set firm dates the
communique at its latest summit was much
more modest than some of the earlier
versions
under discussion oil giant shell is
planning to speed up its plan to cut
emissions
it follows a ruling from a dutch court
saying the firm's plans
weren't good enough shell still plans to
appeal but says it also wants to rise to
the challenge
posed by the decision shell is also
eyeing a possible sale of its holdings
in the largest u.s oil field
swiss voters shot down a plan to reduce
the nation's carbon footprint
they rejected a higher levy on co2
emissions
after claims the measure was too costly
the government
is now heading back to the drawing board
in order to meet its commitment to the
paris climate deal
and that's your green brief
[Music]
thanks jen well with the rise of solar
wind and other renewable energy sources
humanity is racing along a path towards
clean energy
we're already producing more and more of
it but there's plenty of barriers to
overcome to get it
where it needs to be our next guest is
russell gold
and he charted the push to renewables in
his book superpower
one man's quest to transform american
energy
russell great to talk to you so the
issue is that you can create energy you
can harness it then you have to
transport it
is that the biggest pain point
absolutely it's one of the
largest problems right now in the
deployment of renewables in the united
states
the middle of the united states the
planes are an incredible wind resource
the southwest is an incredible solar
resource but that's simply not where
people are where industry is and moving
the electricity that can be generated
there at extraordinarily low cost
to the coast where most people live it's
just incredibly difficult we don't have
the infrastructure right now
and we're really struggling to build it
what does the infrastructure have to
look like
well we're talking about our large uh
transmission lines uh
mostly dc i wrote about a group of
entrepreneurs that were trying to build
a direct current
line i mean this is what's happening in
china it's what's happening in germany
and the united states simply doesn't
have the same kind of transmission
infrastructure
to move power around and and that's
really going to be a problem going
forward in the united states because
it's going to be more difficult to get
access to the extraordinarily
inexpensive renewables and a bigger
grid means that the grid is more robust
and frankly it means it's it's more
protected
from things like a hack or or any kind
of other national security
intrusion but if the electricity itself
is inexpensive is investing in this kind
of distribution
infrastructure expensive it costs a lot
of money to build
transmission lines we're talking the
billions of dollars but every single
person who's looked at this
from from a bigger picture economic
point of view says that that investment
pays back many times over so let's talk
about investment obviously the biden
administration has outlined its
goals for long-term economic spending
kind of a question mark as to how much
of that will actually be realized
but from what you've seen does it go far
enough
it's a huge step in the direction of
creating incentives
for private industry to want to build
these transmission lines i mean one of
the biggest ideas is out there
is a transmission tax credit however
it's not just about money
to build a transmission line is
extraordinarily difficult it is
many times more difficult than to build
something like a natural gas
pipeline a similar piece of
infrastructure the united states makes
it so much easier to build
a buried pipeline in terms of eminent
domain in terms of
streamlining the process building
transmission is just extraordinarily
difficult
and it's not because we want to make it
more difficult
what can the u.s learn from other
countries in that respect
well i i think you know getting back to
this question of streamlining one of the
things that i think would be incredibly
important is that
right now um if you go to a place like
germany if you go to a place like china
if you want to build i mean obviously in
china there's there's no you know
it's it's state-run but in germany if
you want to build a transmission line
you have to meet certain environmental
certain social
hurdles you know you have to sort of
prove you know that the transmission
line is is
what will not disturb too many people
etc
but you have ultimately a regulator you
can go to
to get that answer in the united states
you don't
uh there's no one that will really give
you a final answer and that's why
the decisions get stretched out for five
or ten years well
when you're a private industry and
you're trying to get investors and
you're saying
well we really won't know if we can make
a go of this for five or ten years
that that's that's the kiss of death
it's it's not going to work and so what
the united states could learn from other
countries
is to have a process where if you want
to build transmission
here's what you can do and you'll get a
yes or no answer does this make sense is
this in the national interest
and you'll get it within a certain time
frame two or three years seems
reasonable to me
that's what the united states could
learn from other countries that are
doing this more successfully
all right russell gold author of
superpower one man's quest to transform
american energy thank you so much
coming up how do you bring people out of
poverty
without wrecking the climate in the
process we'll explore how one company is
helping
rural communities power themselves this
is bloomberg green
[Music]
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kaylee lynes and this
is bloomberg green well a rural village
in kenya
might not be the first place you'd
expect to find electric motorcycles
internet service and thriving local
businesses
but a solar powered mini grid is making
it all possible
u.s base energy startup power hive is on
a mission to supply clean energy to
rural communities around the world
bringing economic opportunity without
the need for fossil fuels
in africa 650 million people don't have
electricity
don't have access to power don't have
access to an
industry people who would otherwise have
been very productive
if they'd had the means if they had the
capital
[Music]
it's really important that we don't lose
sight of these people
in our bid to grow our economies and
become more industrialized
one of the toughest problems in the
world is how do you bring people out of
extreme poverty
without wrecking the climate in the
process
conventional wisdom says it'll require
the burning of enough fossil fuels
to cancel out any progress the developed
world makes on emissions
but here in rural kenya a small
experiment is underway to see if it's
possible to have the economic uplift
without the environmental catastrophe
[Music]
power hive is the first privately
licensed utility in kenya
we currently operate about 25 village
level microgrids
we're generating our power from solar
we're storing that energy
in batteries when i started in this
business 20 years ago the price per watt
of a solar panel was five six dollars
now it's 20 cents
it's opened up a huge opportunity in
africa to deliver energy
a micro or mini grid like the ones built
by power hive
is a power system that supplies enough
electricity for a small community
schools and homes get electric light and
internet service
agricultural labor like maize milling
doesn't have to be done by hand anymore
electric pressure cookers eliminate the
need to chop down trees
or burn charcoal to make meals all of
these things raise the standard of
living
but there's one big problem when we
first came into kenya
we quickly realized that our consumers
are
too poor to pay for energy
[Music]
many grids have been around for a long
long time the problem is is that there
hasn't been an economic model to support
the long-term
operations of these grids it forced us
to have to think about how
we can support our customers in
generating enough
income that they can sustain themselves
and then also create a good energy
customer for us as a business
in most rural communities in kenya
subsistence farmers would keep maybe 20
chicken
and these would be primarily for eggs
they might sell or consume themselves
really
but electricity along with some startup
capital from power hive
has changed all that powered appliances
like heat lamps and incubators
can transform chicken rearing into a
profitable business
it's a virtuous cycle for power hive
they give their customers the money and
guidance to start
businesses that use their electricity
and then a portion of the income from
those businesses
pays for the electricity
[Music]
you also find the community members who
do see successful businesses
get inspired to do that themselves and
all of that wouldn't have happened
if they hadn't had the exposure or
understood how it can be done or that it
can be done
[Music]
recently power hive has invested in a
new business
leasing electric vehicles to people in
the villages and in nearby kisi town
my name is bryan adore i'm running the
ground operations for this ev project in
this region of kenya what we're trying
to do here
is convert all conventional bikes from
petrol
engines to electric motors
beyond just getting from place to place
motorbikes are key to generating income
in this region
where they're often used as taxi
vehicles or for transporting goods to
market
and while making the switch from gas to
electric is obviously cleaner
there are some more tangible benefits as
well
maintaining electric bikes is way more
cheaper than
maintaining a conventional bike in terms
of servicing
electric vehicles they have fewer moving
parts they don't require
oil you know here people are spending
around 10 us dollars every two weeks
for the maintenance costs so if we can
save somebody one or two dollars a day
it's a very very big deal it's still
early days for mini grid companies like
power hive
and it remains to be seen how big the
industry's impact can be
a study by bloomberg nef found that
electricity from solar hybrid mini grids
is still expensive for many rural
customers
and the sector suffers from a lack of
investment
meanwhile large-scale renewables are
booming
bulk solar and wind are the most
competitive new sources of energy in
most of the world today
but with hundreds of millions of people
still living beyond the reach of major
grids
there's a massive opportunity to improve
lives without the climate paying the
cost
our business model if it works you know
can really change
what development means and what we're
trying to do
is create a model that can be deployed
anywhere
in rural communities across the globe
we have hundreds of millions of people
that are going to be joining the modern
economy
and you know these customers cannot do
so in a carbon
unfriendly way and here in kenya
we're showing that you can sort of
create this model which
you know we hope is actually going to
serve africa for generations
that's it for this week's edition but
keep the conversation going
follow us on twitter at climate i'm
kaylee lines
and this is bloomberg green
you